[موسيقى]
هواوي وقعت اتفاقيه مع وزاره الاتصالات
السعوديه
لانشاء
هاي سبيد موبايل انترنت يعني
بحجم 10 جيجا وايت جيجا بايت في الثانيه
التعاون على انشاء انترنت سريع للمملكه
وايضا كلاوتك
الحوسبه السحابيه داخل السعوديه وبالتالي
هذا يعتبر
وخلق محتوى محلي داخل السعوديه
[موسيقى]
قطاع التقني او الاقتصاد الرقمي المملكه
اليوم تركز على هذا الجانب لانه يعوضها عن
الحاجه الى كثافه العماله وايضا يجعل منها
منطقه جذب واستقطاب بالنسبه للاستثمارات
الاجنبيه لاننا اليوم في عالم يعني يزداد
فيه
الاعتماد على الاقتصاد الرقمي الذي يتجاوز
اكثر من 11 تريليون حاليا ومتوقع ان يصل
الى 40 او 50 تريليون خلال العقدين او
الثلاثاء القادم
[موسيقى]